you dare enter this [ __ ] house on a
Wednesday you got [ __ ] problems you
understand me
greetings [ __ ] uncle Joey a
Wednesday the 19th the [ __ ] July
you're alive that's the most important
thing once you're alive you made it you
got another [ __ ] day to let these
[ __ ] know who's running things
you understand me cuz that's that listen
if you're leaving the house today I
can't wait you're gonna lose you gotta
leave the house it's on the [ __ ]
coconut you gonna leave the house
thinking who the [ __ ] am I gonna stab to
there to get my [ __ ] lunch
money you understand me there's no haha
there's no he-he's there's nothing you
think when I wait I'm a comic on stage
the rest of the [ __ ] time I'm a
[ __ ] Savage
if you hang out around me you don't
think I'm cracking stupid [ __ ] jokes
all day
and trying to make now I don't give a
[ __ ] we're trying to put pieces together
what I've been doing all my [ __ ] life
and I suggest you do the same you
understand me your crap all the stupid
jokes you want and call people different
names on Twitter but if you ain't making
it happen
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] you could
wipe your ass with that [ __ ] it's
Wednesday it's a beautiful day to be
alive but most importantly you got you
because without you you got nothing you
understand all these guys walking around
with goatees trying to be something dang
got them don't wake up on them and their
50 got a big black dick up their ass no
[ __ ] ask themselves what happened you
were never you me I don't give a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] think you understand
me when I go to the supermarket I'm
there by myself paying for those
groceries well I'll see you
[ __ ] there with a handout and
that's your mentality tell all these
[ __ ] suck my dick and call me
Shirley I was born in 1940 I ain't on
your [ __ ] bandwagon [ __ ]
when you came out of your mom's snatch
and they cut that little cord that's the
day you want your own what makes you
think anybody owes you [ __ ] something
nobody owes you dick
you got to get up in the morning and
sharpen your dick wash your [ __ ]
powder your nutsack salute the flag and
go out there like you own the
[ __ ] place if not they smell
that [ __ ] on you I'm I fear is rampant
but I don't [ __ ] express it when I
walk around I got the biggest dick on
the street and put me to the test
[ __ ] anyway
four o'clock today podcast number 500
you know why because they use [ __ ]
savages that's why 500 [ __ ] episodes
because of you guys to a week so I thank
you with all my heart
manly thank you from the bottom of my
fat little [ __ ] hearts because you
guys are the real deal
you guys didn't buy into some [ __ ]
faith Nasir you guys brought into
realness so your parents did a good job
you are the rest of these [ __ ]
and following all these fake flops and
that tell you what you want to hear I
don't give a [ __ ] jack I tell you what I
want to [ __ ] tell you so I
congratulate you for having balls and
for being one of [ __ ] uncle joey's
nephews and living your life tip top
Magoo II understand
now enough with the [ __ ] it's time
to smoke some [ __ ] reefer
Illinois I got this [ __ ]
perennial is the one that not Lee's
eyeball out Monday night he's still
walking around with red eyeballs why
because we only smoke them or the
[ __ ] best okay we're not part of that
huh I smoked sativas cuz I wanna a body
hi I'm micro dose go [ __ ] yourself
alright all that [ __ ] is made up from
these [ __ ] little weed [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've been smoking weed since
Jesus left you understand me
so you want to know about the reef uncle
Joey's right [ __ ] here
plain and simple everything else is
background music you don't see me with a
felt on a joint get the [ __ ] out of my
face the Mighty Clouds of Joy [ __ ] the
ice house tonight is sold out what we do
have tickets left
isn't it Morgana and I'm gonna tell you
what's gonna happen next Friday and go
we're gonna go see Joey but now that
Jesus is slow
I've been telling you that's my part of
the [ __ ] country
Philly represents kantham represents and
Sock'em represents [ __ ] toms river'
represents Seaside represents [ __ ] you
don't tell me we got the whole [ __ ]
Jersey crew coming down and bring your
[ __ ] body vest and that's it [ __ ]
tell you
what else we got we got nothing we have
the fifth hundred [ __ ] episode because
of you guys so I don't know what the
[ __ ] and don't worry about who it is
it's gonna rock your [ __ ] world cuz
that's how we do it because all that
matters is the [ __ ] conversation the
conversation you're gonna hit tonight
this afternoon's gonna rock your world
Shareef is on fire today
[ __ ] tremendous you understand me and
that's it and that's that I don't have
much of the tight what I'm trying to
tell you is I love you [ __ ]
thank you for giving me the opportunity
and thank you for letting me coming to
your [ __ ] life I'm a normal little
[ __ ] rough around the edges but you
know what you guys did all right your
parents did all right because they
showed you they showed you trust they
showed you trust hey I'm a fucked-up
dude but I ain't [ __ ] crazy
I went from [ __ ] zero and nothing but
my [ __ ] self the understanding with
the listen I stayed out of [ __ ] jail
criminal you follow me said you must had
a jail you wanna be [ __ ] human being
you hang out with Uncle Joe I'll keep
you out of jail and then there's steps
along the way then we teach you how to
make a little buckle ah then you know
things happen well anyway you know I
love your [ __ ]
you guys are that big so that's why I do
what the [ __ ] I do at the end of the
week to be honest right we think we do
another Bowl what would either come some
half a [ __ ] [ __ ] when they show up
let's smoke a half a joint this is so
strong that's a fatty when we go we go
listen if you ain't [ __ ] shootin in
that line like a savage stay home
got a Starbucks hang out with those
[ __ ] that 3% is your family if you
want to be a 1% like uncle Joey [ __ ]
stick around let's smoke a [ __ ] Bowl
let's chitchat a little bit nothing like
smoke don't we they got jiu-jitsu I got
a podcast I got a little meeting and I
got the [ __ ] ice house that's my
[ __ ] day alright I've been up since
7:00 ready to go doing [ __ ] they can
carry [ __ ] and I called my hair dry with
a spool you know me go I'm an
all-purpose type of [ __ ]
but anyway Joey enough with the
chitty-chat let's [ __ ] smoke a ball
when we go we go cops up you understand
me again H Wednesday you got a job to do
you got a [ __ ] mission ok
this is like the old Mission Impossible
village i sat down on a bench and a tape
recorder and I'm that [ __ ] tape
recorder you know what I'm telling you
to go out there and live your [ __ ]
like go for it today don't take no for
an answer don't take [ __ ] from nobody go
for it today you think I got over here
because I took [ __ ] from people I didn't
know for fun who gives a [ __ ] of one
night ouch one door closes another one
opens you understand me and you take
that from me a [ __ ] loser one door
closes another one opens you just gotta
stay on that [ __ ] and let them
know you're relaxed you follow me you're
relentless you're [ __ ] creepin while
they're sleeping that's what I do kind
of it
but that's it that's that
I'm gonna go take care of some [ __ ] and
I'll get back to you [ __ ] later
this afternoon 4 o'clock Pacific to fit
hunger episode and I want to thank you
guys from the bottom of my heart like I
said what are you I got nothing
don't forget Ari Shaffir special on
Netflix [ __ ] hilarious
I watched the the half of the first one
last night we'll [ __ ] put it on later
watch it together that's my brother I
love that dude with all my heart you
understand me so please support Irish
you face my main [ __ ] man and that's
it and that's that hope you guys have a
great day I hope you guys stay out of
harm's way I hope you guys keep your
eyes open Dante [ __ ] from nobody
remember today's your [ __ ] day
whatever happened yesterday before
[ __ ] that is your day book the only
get the N&K mama della bingo